kind of like america's legacy is complex
all right here with reaction former
speaker of the house newt gingrich i'll
add to that mr speaker he supports court
packing ending cash bail
ending fossil fuels supports crt in
school
called the trump tax cuts uh
bill that wanted to kill kids
no limits on abortion at all whatsoever
there's your georgia candidate can he
win in georgia
well look i i think the
biden warnock ticket is going to go down
in flames uh my guess is he'll be lucky
to get 46 of the vote by the time this
is over he's far too radical for georgia
uh he should have been defeated
two years ago and as people get to know
his record and get to realize how much
he's a racist how much he's hostile to
america how much he's tied into joe
biden
i think all these things come to bear
and you're going to have a very tough
next couple months food prices are going
to go back up
electricity prices you know 20 million
american families now
are behind in paying their electric
bills because electricity prices are
going up you have a murder rate in
atlanta atlanta actually according to
channel 11
has a higher per capita crime rate than
chicago
so i think that all the different
factors on the other hand you haven't
hershel walker
somebody who in most of georgia is seen
as a heroic figure
not just a remarkable person for his
athletic ability but somebody who's been
in over 400 military bases talking to
young men and women about ptsd and about
coping with real problems somebody who's
created a business and created jobs and
somebody who i think is a sincere
genuine down-home conservative the
contrast couldn't be wider than between
walker and warnock
you know and and like ron johnson and
like jd vance and and like dr oz in in
pennsylvania the smearing the slandering
is is oh
so over the top i know you lived it
yourself when you were speaker but
they're doing it early
will it be effective will that overcome
the state of the economy the state of
our borders uh america's position in the
world
no look look if you've got a a biden
kelly ticket in arizona where kelly
could not get a single
additional border patrol agent but did
vote for 87 000 more irs agents if you
have a candidate like fetterman who is
totally for releasing murderers uh and a
biden fetterman ticket in pennsylvania
and well
you forgot wait you forgot country you
forgot legalizing heroin that's
important
safe shooting zones i i think it's fair
to say that i i'm fair that's fair to
say you think of something radical
fetterman's for it although currently
he's hiding i think he just turned down
a kdka debate uh the fact is that uh
fetterman represents
may well be the most radical candidate
in the democratic party this year for
the u.s senate
campaign because pennsylvania is not a
radical state
by the way he's a trust fund brat never
had a real job in his entire life tries
to look like a
blue collar worker with his hoodie and
tattoos the guy's never had a job in his
life he got
he got his home for a dollar from his
family but he acts like a tough guy he's
campaigned a whopping 15 minutes in the
general election but all right mr
speaker we'll have you on periodically
as usual you're right on the mark and
we'll follow all of it closely thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else